dans les grands disparus cette année
c'est vrai qu'on on aurait pu rajouter
les remettants parce que bon on en a et
on les adore
mais c'est vrai que je vous cache pas
que j'ai eu pas mal de défection j'ai
beaucoup de désistements un rapport 1 à
popol exécuté neuf désistement vrai dire
je crois que je pourrais créer un césar
du meilleur désistement
non parce que sincèrement les acteurs
qui m'ont annulé mais coûtent ils n'ont
jamais aussi bien joué de leur vie
jamais ils ont tout donné c'est un an
mais c'était le rôle de leur vie y avait
toutes les émotions dans leur message la
tristesse l'émotion le regret et de
leurs biens alors concerner les mecs
attention moi j'ai des acteurs qui sont
devenus mes féministes du jour au
lendemain des actrices solidaires entre
elles mais soudainement alors pour
annuler il ya eu plusieurs techniques
les plus courageux m'ont appelé par le
biais de leurs agents et les autres ils
m'ont annulée par le biais de la nôtre
vocal quelle invention divine la note
vocale ce extraordinaire
en fait tu enregistres au tout ce que tu
veux dire à et tu l'envoies directement
un temps je peux pas dire interlocuteur
parce que tu peux pas interloqué
justement tu comment encore un symbole
quand tu te prends sur la gueule et que
tu peux pas réagir à sa victime
voilà c'est extraordinaire en plus vont
les acteurs c'est mieux mais si peu mais
ils peuvent l'être le ton tu vois c'est
mieux que les textos tu peux refaire les
prises et à leur magie de la technologie
la note vocale elle s'auto détruit
c'est l'outil de l'époque
est ce que vous vous rendez compte que
c'est l'outil idéal pour la lâcheté
c'est merveilleux vraiment messieurs
dames
je vous le conseille vivement même pour
refuser un scénario allez-y c'est mortel
en tout cas moi je peux vous dire que le
cinéma français se porte très très bien
parce que le nom d'acteur qui tourne ce
soir
non mais vous pouvez pas imaginer là il
ya des [ __ ] de film qui se prépare
avec des castings de malades
lien c'est dommage franchement tu es pas
de cérémonial et prochaine parce qu'elle
va tous des chiens